Joseph stalin ran the Savi with as as
well known and iron grip.
But it wasn't just his ruthlessness,
uh,
that was remarkable.
It was the way in which he's structured
governance so that it was almost
impossible for any to Soviet citizens to
have a private relationship that was
not,
uh,
in some sense,
known to and subject to stolen.
So he was the node through which all
other nodes had to go to communicate.
And Stalin who was famously paranoid,
was suspicious about any interaction
between the Soviet citizens and
especially between the Soviet citizen
and a foreigner that he didn't know
about it.
Really interesting feature of hierarchy
that doesn't get understood,
I think nearly well enough is that if
you are a hierarchical ruler,
you are right to be paranoid.
And it's not just the paranoid people
tend to become a dictators.
It's more that if you're a dictator,
you need to be paranoid because the real
threat to a hierarchy is a success for
the organized social network.
A social network,
independence of the hierarchy of the big
guy is the real threat.
Once saw that,
for example,
in Poland,
why did Poland,
of all the communist regimes get into
trouble first?
Because there was a really well
organized civil society,
all voluntary association,
some religious,
some north that formed a network even
before the solidarity trade union came
along.
Um,
that's lethal to a hierarchical system,
which is why Stalin was right.
If you want to put it this way,
to be paranoid about social networking
that he didn't control or didn't know
about it,
he understood that it doesn't take too
many additional edges in the network to
destroy the dominance of that central
node.
So one way of thinking about this is
imagine a paramedic,
old structure.
Imagine something kind of like a
Christmas tree and there was the big guy
like the ferry on top of the Christmas
tree.
But imagine that on this Christmas tree,
the lights are just connected to the
ferry.
They're not connected to one another.
Uh,
and therefore the theory decides if the
lights go on or off.
It's,
it's a peculiar kind of Christmas tree
that that's essentially a hierarchical
network.
It wouldn't take too many connections as
it were lateral or horizontal
connections between the lights to reduce
the centrality of the ferry on the tree.
Uh,
and ultimately you could end up
illuminating the tree without needing,
uh,
the ferry altogether.
So I think that's why dictators,
high rocks need to be paranoid.
Read the plays of Shakespeare.
The suspicion that always seems to haunt
any of Shakespeare's kings is that there
is some kind of plot,
some cabal,
some conspiracy going on.
Um,
and if you read the history of European
monarchy,
very often those suspicions were well
founded.
What we call social networks look like
conspiracies to absolute rulers.
And that's why very often in history,
the term seems to overlap what looks
like a social network to you and me.
If we're in,
it looks like a plot to the king.
If you want to see the advantages of a
hierarchical system of government,
take a trip to China and,
uh,
you'll see a system which is
extraordinarily high rock calls.
Xi Jinping is top man.
This system is good at doing engineering
projects.
If this system decides on building high
speed rail networks around China,
it can do it with astonishing speed.
If the system decides that it's going
to,
uh,
build cities in the expectation that
there will be a population to inhabit
them,
it can do that.
And so one of the most impressive
aspects of the last 30 years of human
history has been the spectacular growth
of the Chinese economy.
And that has been in large measure the
results of a highly effective
hierarchical system of planning.
Of course,
you would be naive if you went to
China's then didn't see some of the
problems with doing that.
Uh,
the problems of pollution that have been
a characteristic feature of modern
Chinese life.
There's lots of the problem of
corruption.
This is an everyday topic of
conversation in China.
At one party,
hierarchical system of government isn't
accountable.
It's above the law.
And officials,
uh,
have routinely skimmed off a huge sums
of money to line their own pockets.
None of this comes as any news to people
who read hi,
a great book.
The road to serfdom since the mid 20th
century classical liberal scholars have
said that the planned economy is bound
to be inefficient and it's bound to lead
to corruption and other abuses of power.
I think most people who think that way,
and I include myself in that group,
were taken by surprise by the success of
China's economic growth strategy.
Can this system endure through this 21st
century?
That is a huge question for China's
leaders and indeed for the world.
If you are like me,
skeptical about that of political
centralization,
you'll kind of sitting waiting for
something to go wrong.
Because the defects of hierarchical
system of government tends to be that
it's not responsive to,
to signals from down below that top
down.
Governance tends to be somewhat def.
Uh,
not only does it not necessarily get
market signals,
it may miss out on political dissidents,
political discontent or to put it
differently,
you've created through rapid
industrialization,
the biggest middle class in all of
history,
the biggest bourgeoisie in history.
And if Karl Marx,
we're here sitting next to me,
uh,
I think he'd agree that that was very
hard to reconcile with.
The system devised a bimalleolar Dong to
centralize power in the hands of a
single party marks would expect the
Borzois z in China to do what the
European bourgeoisie did in the 19th
century.
Demand property rights,
and therefore the rule of law to protect
property rights and therefore some
elements of representation in
government.
So even from a Marxist perspective,
something has to change.
So hierarchical systems of government
over time tend at some point to suffer a
loss of legitimacy,
a challenge from below.
And we've seen that.
We saw it in the history of the Soviet
Union,
but we've seen it else were much less
sophisticated hierarchical systems like
the military regimes of Latin America or
the presidential regimes of the Middle
East,
uh,
came to grief in some cases well before
the Soviet Union did.
Mm.